y diferentes moléculas pueden absorber
diferentes longitudes de onda y si una
molécula puede absorber luz en la región
ultravioleta visible del espectro
electromagnético entonces podemos
encontrar la longitud o longitudes de
onda que son absorbidas por ese
compuesto usando un espectrofotómetro
uve visible lo que hace es irradiar una
muestra con luz en un cierto rango de
longitudes de onda que van desde
aproximadamente 200 hasta 800 nanómetros
con lo que obtendremos un espectro de
absorción este es el espectro de
absorción para el 13 butadieno y podemos
ver que esta molécula absorbe más
aproximadamente aquí y si bajamos
podemos saber a qué longitud de onda
corresponde bueno está un poco antes de
los 220 nanómetros corresponde a 217
nanómetros y a esta longitud le vamos a
llamar lambda máxima
entonces la longitud de onda máxima
absorbida por esta molécula esté
aproximadamente 217 nanómetros absorbe
en la región v ultravioleta por eso él
butadieno no tiene color es transparente
pero analicemos la estructura con más
detalle observen que tenemos 4 carbonos
y cada uno tiene una hibridación sp2 eso
significa que cada carbono tiene un
orbital p así que tenemos 4 orbitales
atómicos y si hablamos de la teoría de
los orbitales moleculares estos 4
orbitales atómicos se combinan para
formar cuatro orbitales moleculares dos
orbitales en las antes y dos orbitales
anti en las antes miren aquí abajo
tenemos los cuatro orbitales moleculares
pero primero vamos a enfocarnos en el
lado izquierdo vamos a ver los orbitales
moleculares en las antes tienen menos
energía
los anti en las antes entonces este
orbital y este son los orbitales
moleculares en las antes
en las antes mientras que éste y este
son los orbitales anti en las antes anti
en las antes y bueno la energía aumenta
así que los orbitales sanz tienen las
antes tienen más energía pero vamos a
analizar nuevamente la estructura del
bota bien y veamos cuántos electrones
que tiene aquí tenemos dos electrones pi
y aquí tenemos otros dos en total
tenemos cuatro electrones pi entonces
nosotros tenemos cuatro electrones pero
donde los ponemos bueno primero vamos a
colocarlos en los orbitales de baja
energía en este orbital molecular en la
santé tenemos dos y en este orbital
molecular también tenemos dos así que
los cuatro electrones pi están en los
orbitales en las antes claro cuando
hablamos del estado fundamental éste es
el estado fundamental o basal del
bien fundamental
ahora vamos a imaginar que hacemos
incidir una luz sobre él butadieno y que
la molécula absorbe energía de esa luz
así que habrá una diferencia de energía
entre los orbitales en particular nos
interesan estos dos orbitales entonces
hay una diferencia de energía entre
estos orbitales el orbital de abajo está
ocupado por electrones y tiene más
energía que éste entonces este es el
orbital molecular ocupado de más alta
energía que por sus siglas en inglés se
conoce como om mientras que este orbital
que es el orbital anti enlazan t como
todavía no está ocupado además tiene
menor energía que éste
este es el orbital molecular desocupado
de más baja energía y por sus siglas en
inglés se conoce como luma así que
cuando hablamos de una molécula que
absorbe energía hay que tomar en cuenta
el orbital
dado de más alta energía omo y el
orbital desocupado de más baja energía
luma porque la diferencia de energía
entre estos dos orbitales es lo que nos
interesa entonces la molécula absorbe
energía y los electrones piqué absorben
esa energía son impulsados a un nivel de
más alta energía así que ahora estamos
hablando del estado excitado excitado
éste es el estado excitado del butadieno
entonces estos dos electrones se quedan
aquí pero uno de estos dos electrones se
queda aquí y el otro absorbe energía así
que es impulsado a un nivel de mayor
energía pasa del orbital omo al orbital
lumo pero para lograr esa transición
tuvo que absorber una cantidad
específica de energía y bueno nosotros
sabemos que la energía proviene de la
luz y también sabemos qué
energía de un fotón es igual a la
constante de planck h por la frecuencia
de la luz no pero miren en el espectro
de absorción tenemos todo en longitudes
de onda así que necesitamos escribir la
energía en términos de longitud de onda
nosotros sabemos que la frecuencia y la
longitud de onda están relacionadas por
la velocidad de la luz que es igual a la
longitud de onda por la frecuencia
entonces la frecuencia es igual a la
velocidad de la luz entre la longitud de
onda y si esto lo sustituimos acá nos
queda que la energía es igual a h por c
/ lambda esto es muy importante porque
nos dice que la energía y la longitud de
onda son inversamente proporcionales así
que podemos decir que una longitud de
onda corresponde a una cantidad
específica de energía entonces esta
diferencia de energía entre el orbital
el humo corresponde a una cierta
longitud de onda por eso aquí en el
espectro de absorción del butt área no
estamos hablando de una longitud de onda
de 217 nanómetros ahora al principio
puede ser confuso porque parece que
tenemos un rango muy amplio de
longitudes de onda que son absorbidas
pero no se preocupen por eso esto solo
es el resultado de las diferentes
vibraciones y rotaciones de la molécula
eso cambia las diferencias de energía un
poco y por eso no vemos una sola
longitud de onda sino más bien esta
señal ancha que corresponde a varias
longitudes de onda absorbidas pero bueno
lo que hay que hacer es buscar la
longitud de onda que se absorbió con más
fuerza y esa será la longitud de onda
que corresponde a la diferencia de
energía entre estos dos orbitales ok
ahora veamos otra molécula en lugar del
butadieno ahora tenemos
si analizamos esta molécula podemos ver
que tenemos dos electrones para 12
electrones pi ya sabemos que estos
electrones estarán en el orbital
molecular en la santé
pero déjenme dibujar una línea en este
diagrama ok entonces este es nuestro
orbital molecular en la santé en la
santé y nosotros tenemos 12 electrones
pi vamos a ponerlos y después bueno aquí
arriba está el orbital molecular anti
enlazan t también llamado pi asterisco
entonces hay una diferencia de energía
entre el orbital molecular en la santé y
el orbital molecular anti enlazan t que
sería nuestra delta iv y ya dijimos que
esto corresponde a una cierta longitud
de onda entonces cuando impulsamos uno
de los electrones pídele tan al el
electrón pasa de pi
y asterisco podemos decir que la
molécula absorbe energía y la energía
corresponde a una longitud de onda en
este caso la diferencia de energía del
orbital pi al pi asterisco es de 180
nanómetros está por debajo del rango en
el que se mide cuando usamos un
espectrofotómetro uve visible pero aquí
tenemos otra posibilidad voy a resaltar
un par de electrones libres en el
oxígeno
este es un par de electrones que no
forman un enlace podemos decir que son
electrones no en las antes los
electrones que no forman enlaces ocupan
un orbital anti enlazan t que como ya
dijimos tiene más energía que el orbital
enlazan t así que otra posibilidad a
esto le llamaremos n es un orbital no
enlazan t
en la santé aquí tenemos dos electrones
y estos electrones tendrán una
transición diferente aún estamos
hablando de pi asterisco el orbital anti
enlazan t pero en este caso tenemos una
transición de n api asterisco ya que
tenemos este carbón y lo así que en este
caso no sólo hablamos de los electrones
pi sino también de los electrones libres
que hay en el carbono pero ahora
pensemos en la diferencia de energía
miren aquí tenemos una diferencia de
energía más pequeña esta diferencia es
más pequeña que ésta y qué pasa con la
longitud de onda absorbida bueno si
tenemos una diferencia de energía más
pequeña como la energía y la longitud de
onda son inversamente proporcionales
entonces aquí tenemos una longitud de
onda mayor en esta transición se absorbe
una longitud de onda diferente que
resulta
de aproximadamente 290 nanómetros
entonces al pasar de n a pi asterisco
hay una diferencia de energía más
pequeña pero que corresponde a una
longitud de onda mayor así que conforme
disminuye la diferencia de energía entre
los orbitales aumenta la longitud de
onda absorbida hablaremos más sobre eso
en los siguientes vídeos y también
veremos cómo se relaciona con el color